i'd i'd love to
ask you because you were an early
investor in robin hood
and you're sort of you're in a very nice
place
of uh being a huge supporter of the sort
of wall street bets
yep kind of distributed power of the
people
and at the same time uh because of
you being an investor like
intellectually
giving a chance to robin hood in this
kind of chaotic time of conversations
to think about like well what did they
do right what did they do wrong
yeah so you have a kind of a balanced
view on the whole thing which is really
nice
is there we've talked about what
robinhood did
right i think can you uh sort of
steal man uh chamata's argument
of uh what robin hood did wrong in the
last few days
yeah i mean their communication is
always the number one issue with these
startups right
and if you you have to get ahead of any
problem
and you have to put all the bad news out
immediately and in the case of robinhood
it seems based on what you know has been
in the papers and what robinhood said
publicly
is that they had this kind of liquidity
crisis right where
they were being uh because of these
exchanges telling them you have to put
up this amount of money in collateral
and them being pinned at number one
in the app store there were so many
people trying to buy five shares of this
stock five shares of this meme stock
that it kind of broke their system and
then the people who cleared the trades
for them
they said you got to put up a billion
dollars 2 billion 3 billion well you
can't do that overnight
and i think that they were an
uncomfortable situation of
like going on tv and saying uh we have a
liquidity crisis
like that could be like a run on the
bank everybody then logs in at the same
time to
robinhood and tries to sell every share
they own because they're afraid that the
whole thing's going to collapse right so
i think there was this kind of like
black swan event and they probably
didn't communicate it all that well
at the center of that this is this is
really interesting maybe you can comment
on the nature of communication
uh vlad the ceo yeah the guy you met at
the bar
yeah i think at the center of the
communication right yep
so elon is an example of a guy who also
is at the center of the communication
for his particular set of companies
and that you know on twitter seems to be
a really powerful way to communicate
yeah and there was something this is me
saying it yeah there was something about
vlad that sounded like he's hiding stuff
that yeah as opposed to elon it doesn't
sound like he's hiding stuff it could be
the nature the the
the beat the timing of the conversation
same thing with mark zuckerberg he
mark zuckerberg for some reason often
sounds like he's hiding something yeah
and then there's like jack dorsey is
much less so
yeah and i don't know what that is about
the ceos it makes you
trust them and not might be the perm
point in time
um like in terms of escape velocity uh
you know there might be non-disclosures
in place that we're not aware of
where they're not allowed to talk about
certain relationships i see and
and and that results like in vlad in
this case and that results in you being
like
acting weird and nervous or nervous yeah
it could just be the person is nervous
you know so
it's really hard to be building one of
these companies and you're at scale and
you know oh my lord the entire thing's
coming apart and you're the most hated
person for that day you know how the
rage cycle works and the
the media is just so crazy when they
get their hooks into something i saw it
happen with uber we saw it happen with
facebook
and even tesla you know there were times
when auto
people did stupid things with autopilot
and it's like yeah okay somebody's
watching a movie
and sleeping in their car yeah or
leaving the driver's seat against
all the rules of autopilot and somehow
tesla's responsible for that it's like
we have people who stand on top of their
motorcycles and drive down the road on a
motorcycle
and we don't blame yamaha for or harley
davidson for some idiot standing on the
seat of their motorcycle on a highway
going 60 miles an hour we just say
that person's an idiot but when new
technology comes out
we blame the technology not the person
operating it
yeah and if you are going to operate
uh we basically vilify and demonize i
think that's that is part of it like
when the person at
i remember airbnb we always thought what
if somebody trashes your apartment
and then sure enough a bunch of meth
heads rented this poor woman's apartment
she left all of her stuff in it and then
a bunch of meth heads had a drug party
destroyed her apartment ripped up all
her photos and went crazy
and we knew that day would happen but
nobody remembers it now but it was the
number one story on every news channel
because wow that's an exciting story and
i just thought to myself
i wonder if there are any parties in
hotel rooms where the hotel room is
being trashed and people are doing
drugs and and crazy things like yes
that's basically
every hotel in los angeles right now is
being destroyed by some rock band
that's throwing a tv out the window like
we expected in
uh you know a hotel we just didn't
expect it in somebody's house with
airbnb and then airbnb
created rules around you can't rent an
airbnb for a party
uh and they learn so i think there's a
learning curve with these companies and
they do get to scale
at a level that is unprecedented it used
to take
decades for a company to become an
international phenomenon now it happens
in two three four years
i mean look at clubhouse this thing went
from being you know a private beta six
months ago to being the number one app
in germany
and in japan and here like just like
that boom
and it's because there's an ecosystem
that has never existed
the app store then there's uh payments
online
everybody and then everybody has a super
computer in their pocket when we
the thing people got wrong about
entrepreneurship technology
and business you know over the last
couple decades was just how big the
market was
and then how quickly you could um you
know
achieve relevancy in these markets
we thought the market was like the 60
million homes would broadband
and originally it was like maybe 10 or
20. then it became 60 million
then i was like okay well how many how
many hours are you at your desktop
computer well like probably at our
computers for five hours a day ten hours
a day at work
three hours a day on our own and then i
was like yeah nobody's on their desktop
computer everybody's on their mobile
phone
and oh and by the way they have it with
them so the people with mobile phones
are now using
this high-speed device with an app store
with their credit card in it yeah
in the early days of the internet people
were scared to put their credit card on
the internet that was considered a
really dumb thing to do if you put your
credit card on the internet you're gonna
lose all your money they're gonna
they're gonna hack you or whatever and
now it's just amazing to me how quickly
when a company hits
how quickly it can get to a million
subscribers or 10 million or a billion
users right
and there's all these networks like
social networks that allow the spread
of uh the viral spread of like a new
startup a new
company uh a new app to be announced i
mean
anything was an idea a podcast right
like i mean single thinking just as a
single meme could change the world
speaking of clubhouse i mean yeah i just
wanna we're saying so many interesting
things but
there there was a magical moment with
vlad and elon on clubhouse
yes is there do you have thoughts about
that
interaction uh which felt like
so many uh aspects of this whole
situation feels like
totally novel surreal like it's defining
world
era like it is yes like a billionaire
the richest
human on earth is interviewing uh
yeah the person at the center of one of
the
most interesting mass scale
like uh power battles in finance
ever you know perhaps by the way seven
movies have been sold
and two weeks just think about how fast
things are moving
this thing happens yeah like people had
the idea to short the stock six months
ago
they start doing their research they
build an army they execute the trade
the system goes down robin hood raises
three and a half billion dollars in four
days
elon is interviewing them on clubhouse
on sunday after the wednesday it
happened and now here we are
it's 10 days later yeah doesn't it feel
like it's been 10 months yeah it's been
10 days lex
it's been 10 days 10 years there's like
a new president
all these things and everyone forgot
like what was an insurrection
by the way we also had a revolution at
the capitol where
a bunch of crazy people who have guns
and body armor and then a bunch of them
who are just yoloing in cosplay
yeah took over the capital
you